okay
now
we slip one thing by you we said
um in the south africa in south africa
the the risk for heart disease is about
five five percent in this category in
this age category
but in our sample we've got 160 cases
and 302 controls
so in the sample we show in a risk of
0.35
so it seems like the model is going to
be off it's going to estimate
probabilities too high
well this is case control sampling is
one of the favorite tools in
epidemiology especially when you have a
rare disease
you take all the cases you can find
and then you can just sample from the
controls
and the reason is is that for the
logistic regression model
it turns out that you can estimate the
regression parameters of interest these
are the coefficients of the x's in this
case
accurately
that's if the model is correct
but the constant term will be incorrect
and then you can just go ahead and
correct the constant term by a simple
transformation
and in fact for those that are
interested i just give you the
transformation
so pi tilde here is the apparent
risk of heart disease in this case in
our population which is 0.35
and this is after all this is just the
logic transformation of the prior
probability
or the prior parent probability
and here's the logic transformation of
the true risk
which is pi in this case point zero five
and so we take the loaded transformation
of those two and we correct the
intercept this is the currently
estimated intercept and we correct it by
adding in the log odds of the true
probability subtract the apparent one
that corrects the intercept maybe it's
worth saying a little bit
about case control sampling i think why
the sampling is done this way right one
thing we could have done instead or the
investigators could have done was to
take maybe a thousand people
and to follow them for 20 years right
and to record the risk factors and then
see who gets heart disease and we think
about five percent of a good heart
disease
and that's that's a valid thing to do
but the problem is it takes 20 years and
maybe
more than a few thousand people to get
enough actually the thousand people
would get what
50 cases right right but so that's not
very practical we need a large sample
and we need many years to do it right
case control sampling says well let's
not do things prospectively like that
let's rather
find people who we already know have
heart disease
or don't have heart disease and then
sample sample them
and now in the proportion in this case
you know it will take 160 cases and 302
controls and then record the risk
factors
so we we start with cases and controls
so and we get lots of cases and we can
do this without waiting 20 years we can
do it right now
and then we record the risk factors
that's a good point rob um and that
that's a very popular in epidemiology
there are the the other issues involved
with case control sampling retrospective
sampling
but we won't take that up now but that's
that's the reason it's so popular
on the same issue you know in in many
modern data sets
we have
you know we'll have very imbalanced
situations for example if you're
modeling the click-through rate on an ad
on a web page
the probability of someone clicking is
is less than one percent maybe
0.005 or even smaller 0.001
which means if you just take a random
sample
of subject who've been exposed to ads
you're going to get very very few ones
and a huge amount of zeros
okay
and and these data sets gets really
large so
the question is do we need to use all of
that zero one data to fit the models
well from what we've told you no you can
take a sample of the controls
and this picture over here just gives an
indication of of the trade-off
the point is the main point is that
ultimately the variance of your
parameter estimates has to do with this
the number of cases that you got which
is a smaller class
and so what this plot shows is it's
showing the variance of the coefficients
as a function of the
the case control ratio
or in fact the control case ratio and
what it says is when you've got about
five or six to one the variance kind of
levels off yeah
and and so there's diminishing returns
in in getting even more controls
so if you've got a very sparse situation
sample about five or six
uh controls for every case
and and and now you can work with a much
more manageable data set so it's very
handy especially in in modern extremely
large um data sets
so just a comment about what this case
control sampling is um
the most obvious way to sort to study
the risk factors for heart disease would
be to take a large group of people maybe
a thousand or a hundred thousand people
follow them for maybe 20 years record
their risk factors and then see who gets
heart disease and who doesn't after 20
years if you're still around if you're
still running if we're still around
right
now that actually is a good good way to
do things except it's very expensive it
takes a long time you take it i'll get a
lot of people you have to wait for many
years case control sampling is more
attractive because what you do is rather
than
taking people and
following them forward in time you
you sample people who you know have
heart disease
you sample com you also get a comparison
sample people who do not have heart
disease that controls and then you
record their risk factors so it's much
cheaper and it's much quicker to do and
that's why case control sampling is a
very commonly used technique in
epidemiology okay what if we have uh
more than two classes um can we still do
logistic regression
well we can
um
it easily generalizes to more than two
classes so one and there's various ways
of doing this and one version which
actually is how we do it in in the
glimnet package in r which will you'll
be learning more about is
we have this this exponential form that
we saw before but modified for multiple
classes
so notice in the numerator we've got a e
to the
linear model
and this is for the probability that y
is k given x a small k and we've got say
capital k
classes where k capital k is bigger than
2.
and in the denominator we've just got
the sum of
those exponentials for all the classes
so in this case each class gets a linear
model
its own linear model
and then we just weigh them against each
other with this
exponential
function sometimes called the soft max
function
okay
the mathias students will recognize that
some cancellation is possible
in in this ratio
and that's true and what that means is
actually you only need k minus one
linear functions
as you do in a two class logistic
regression that's somewhat of a detail
and it turns out for our glimnet
application the symmetric this is a more
symmetric uh representation and it's
actually more useful
this multi-class logistic regression is
also referred to as multinomial
regression